.
MARIANNE THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US FOR THE BREAKING NEWS.
NOW TO FOX NEWS ALERT OUT OF
COLEMAN FLORIDA FOR A STORY THAT
SOUNDS STRAIGHT OUT OF THE THE
NETFLIX NARCO AND NOTORIOUS DRUG
LORD KNOWN FOR DECAPITATING
VICTIMS MISSING FROM FEDERAL
CUSTODY THEY CALL HIM LA BARBIE
NOT RELEASED FROM PRISON UNTIL
2056 AND SUDDENLY VANISHED
RUMORS SWIRL FROM A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY TO WITNESS PROTECTION.
JOINING ME NOW FORMER ACTINGS
I.C.E. DIRECTOR FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR TOM NOW TOM YOU'VE
BEEN IN LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR A
LONG TIME QLIEWNS IT MEANS TO
PROTECT THE CASE AS WELL.
WHAT DO YOU SEE PLAN OUT?
>> WELL LOOK LIKE YOU SAID NOT
ONLY IS TOP FLUENT A SINALOA
CARTEL BUT TESTIFIES A HIT MAN
AND KILL DOZENS OF PEOPLE BUT
JUST NOT KILL THEM HE TORTURE
THEM AND FILM AND BEHEAD THEM
AND FILM WHOLE THING THIS MAN IS
JUST A NASTY PERSON.
BUT LOOK HE'S NOT WALKING
STREETS OF THIS COUNTRY.
HE DIDN'T ESCAPE.
COULD THERE BE A OUT FOR THE
ENTIRE NATIONAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES?
THAT ENMOOSE BE ON LOOKOUT FOR
THEM THERE'S NONE.
BUT BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE I
WORK WITH BOP MANY TIMES HE'S
MOVED TO A SECURE LOCATION.
HE'S BEEN MOVED OUT OF THE
GENERAL POPULATION THAT HAS A
LOT OF CARTEL MEMBERS THAT KNOW
WHO IS HE IS AND TAKE REVENGE ON
HIM FOR DOING WHAT I THINK HE'S
ABOUT TO DO SO HE'S OFF --
OFF ON A SECURE LOCATION.
I ACTUALLY THINK IF I HAD TO
GUESS EDUCATED GUESS AT THIS.
HE IS ABOUT READY TO TESTIFY.
HE'S ABOUT READY TO TESTIFY
AGAINST OTHER CARTEL LEADERS AND
MEXICAN OFFICIALS WN SINALOA
CARTEL HAS HANDS IN POCKETS OF
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT --
>> NEXT YES TOM --
ONE OF MY LAW ENFORCEMENT
SOURCES SAY SOMETIMES THEY DON'T
TELL MEXICO BECAUSE MEXICO
LEAKS.
THEY'RE A PART OF IT SOME OF THE
PEOPLE WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT ON
THE SAME TEAM OF THE ENEMY.
SO, OF COURSE, THEY DIDN'T TELL
MEXICO.
>> AND THAT'S PROBABLY WHY
MEXICAN OFFICIALS ARE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS GUY RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHAT IS
ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
LIKE I'VE SAID MANY TIMES WE
WORK WITH MEXICAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT 35 YEARS.
BUT WE PICK AND CHOSE WHAT WE
TOLD THEM BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT.
YOU CAN'T GIVE THEM VALUABLE
INTEL BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN BURNED
AND SHARE WHAT WE THINK WE CAN
SHARE TO NOT DANGER LIVES THIS
YEAR THEY WON'T SHARE IT SHE'S
NOT WALKING STREETS HE'S IN DIS
AND ABOUT --
READY TO DO SOME THINGS FOR
THE --
INTEREST OF SAVING LIVES IN A
STOP THE DARK ON THIS COUNTRY.
>> I HAVE TO ASK WHAT WOULD BE
THE INCENTIVE FOR HIM TO
COOPERATE?
IS HE GOING TO BE BACK ON THE
STREETS OR IS IT FOR A SHORTENED
SENTENCE WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
SPECULATE?
>> A LOT OF THINGS TELL ABOUT
GENERAL POPULATION PUT THEM IN
EASIER PRISON SETTING BUT HE HAS
OVER 30 YEARS LEFT SO MAYBE
KNOCK TEN YEARS OFF SENTENCE AND
EXTRA DIET SOMEPLACE ELSE BUT HE
WAS BOSH IN THE UNITED STATES
ISN'T LIKE --
BUT I'M SURE HE'S WORKING ON
SOME DEAL OR --
YOU KNOW MAYBE FOUND JESUS WHILE
HE WAS IN PRISON I DON'T KNOW.
BUT SOME PEOPLE --
SOME PEOPLE IN MEXICO ARE
STARTING TO PANIC ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN THERE NEXT WEEK
OR TWO.
GLANS HE POWNGDZ JESUS --
I HOPE THAT'S THE CA